franck gaudichaud professeur en histoire
et civilisation de l'amérique latine à
l'université toulouse jean jaurès franck
gaudichaud merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors on observe un côté des
gilles com são paulo c'est le poumon
économique du pays qui poursuivent leur
confinement par la volonté des
gouverneurs d'état mais aussi des maires
et puis de l'autre on le disait on
entend ce président qui continue à dire
que le confinement ne sert à rien qu'est
ce que ça montre finalement que le
président brésilien n'a plus d'autorité
dans son pays
disons que ça montre la profondeur de la
crise politique que traverse le brésil
on a un bol so now effectivement qui
fait qu'à via cavalier seul mais qui
quand même entourée des militaires et
d'une partie de la droite dure
brésilienne mais qui est y compris
contre une partie de ses partisans de
gouverneurs locaux
donc il ya vraiment un divorce très très
fort entre l'exécutif le parlement la
cour suprême et les pouvoirs fédérer les
pouvoirs locaux
donc on peut dire dans un contexte
vraiment catastrophique parce qu'il ya
la pandémie la crise économique et la
crise politique avec un pouvoir qui est
dans une fuite en avant totalement
irresponsable alors on le disait
ingénieurs ball senard haut continue à
nier l'existence du virus
il s'en prend également à l' oms comment
est ce qu'on peut comprendre cette
posture est ce que l ai suivi dans
l'opinion publique
alors oui il ya vraiment une sorte de
c'est une sorte de trump brésilien on
pourrait dire dans ses positions bolson
à eau
il reste avec une base sociale qui est
réel les dernières enquêtes montrent
qu'il est toujours appuyés par 25 30% de
la population
malgré le mécontentement croissant les
concerts de casseroles pour marquer ce
mécontentement dans la gestion de la
pandémie
et puis face à l'économie qui est en
crise et qui va continuer de plus en
plus est en crise
donc ball sonar aux joues un peu son
à tous il mobilise ses bases sociales
les plus les plus conservatrices on l'a
même vu participer à des rassemblements
de l'extrême droite devant le parlement
à brasilia
mais pas sûr qu'ils soient suivis très
très longtemps puisqu'on sait qu'une
partie des militaires sont de plus en
plus mécontents de sa gestion donc il ya
aussi des fractures au sein du bol sonar
isme actuellement qu'est ce qu'on entend
justement de la part de ces militaires
qu'est ce qui les inquiète dans la
posture de leur président disons que
l'on voit au travers du vice président
murat ou et de quelques autres suite à
la démission on l'a plutôt éjecté du
ministre de la santé la démission du
ministre très populaire
serge moreau de la justice on voit des
militaires qui trouvent que bonnart ou
en fait trop et que il à une mauvaise
gestion de la crise alors que des
militaires prétendent incarner disons
une gestion à la fois autoritaire et néo
libéral sur le plan économique mais
aussi à donner des gages disons classe
dirigeante brésilienne et là on voit que
de ce côté là du côté de la bourgeoisie
brésilienne il ya de plus en plus de
mécontentement face à une crise
économique qui arrive très très fort il
y a besoin de stabilité
du point de vue des investisseurs du
grand patronat au brésilien et cette
stabilité pour l'instant ovale saône et
rhône ne la donne pas au pays alors vous
parlez du ministère de la santé le
brésil a franchi le seuil des 10000
morts et des 150000 4 coronavirus ça ce
sont les chiffres officiels communiqués
samedi par le ministère de la santé
vu le contexte dans le pays et est ce
qu'on peut douter de ces chiffres alors
on peut en douter
tout à fait d'une part parce que
d'ailleurs comme en france il n'y a pas
de politique de tests systématiques
donc les statistiques sont tout à fait à
prendre dix ans avec des pincettes et
elles sont très certainement sous-évalué
comme pour l'ensemble de l'amérique
latine
on est aujourd'hui à peut-être douze
mille morts mais certains parlent de
beaucoup plus en sachant qu'on est dans
un contexte sanitaire très très complexe
puisque comme vous savez au brésil on a
des favelas on a peut-être 15 millions
de personnes qui vivent dans des
conditions de très grande précarité
urbaine de logement d'accès à l'eau et
donc on sait que d'ici juin il va voir
explosion des cas de corée le virus est
un système de santé qui n'est pas
préparée à absorber cette explosion la
pandémie alors pour conclure vous le
rappeliez on connaît ce fossé qui existe
entre les brésiliens ceux des quartiers
aisés puis ceux des quartiers très
pauvres vous en parliez les favelas ce
en quoi cette crise finalement du commis
de 19 à encore davantage creusé ce fossé
en fait le coc vide
il n'est qu'un révélateur de la
situation extrêmement inégalitaire de ce
pays l'un des plus inégalitaires de la
planète et on voit vraiment les
statistiques sont effarantes par exemple
un brésilien un afro brésilien à 60% de
chance ou de risque de plus d'être
touché par le cos vide qu'un blanc des
beaux quartiers donc il ya vraiment une
fracture sociale une fracture raciale et
le co vie devient encore plus mettre
l'accent sur ces fractures là dans un
contexte politique catastrophique avec
l'extrême droite à la tête du
gouvernement
merci beaucoup franck gaudichaud d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur en histoire et
civilisation de l'amérique latine à
l'université toulouse jean jaurès